[Music]
hey developers welcome back and now
we're heading into a Super Key topic
area regardless of your company or your
Tech Focus security
so please welcome our next speaker who
is a hybrid multi-cloud fellow he's
going to talk about how to check your
security posture so welcome Jason quick
the global CTO of Devo team Google Cloud
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
hi everyone thanks for joining my
session today and today I'm going to
talk about a very important topic about
checking your security posture in Google
Cloud
so first of all I'd like to give a bit
of background where do we come from and
why I'm on the stage talking about this
so when we first moved to Google Cloud
we decided that we were going pure Cloud
native the number one priority for us
was developed by agility so how do we
get the productivity to build products
and applications on the cloud as fast as
you can and as cleanly as you can
and we also had to combat the clear
changing Cloud landscape with continuous
new features and releases like you see
in the cloud next
all the time so understanding what to
use and what not to use in our Cloud
landscape
so devotee in gcloud is a Google Cloud
managed Services partner with a global
presence which means that we are present
in 18 countries so which means also
different difficult regulations and
different kind of rules they have to
apply for all customers that sit across
the globe
and it's not easy to do
and we also have to pass different
things like the audit so to become
managed Services partner in Google Cloud
you actually get audited by Google
itself and that's kind of stressful at
times so in one section it's about
security how do you maintain a good
security posture so that you can give
secure a peace of mind to your customers
we also have many specializations and in
which of them they go through our
security posture and validate that we
are secure and we are poised to for
success
so it can feel hard to create a secure
Cloud environment because there's so
many rules there's many features things
like organization policies things like
security Command Center things like IM
rules so it can feel high at times to
what do you enable and what do you
disable in your Cloud environment
so a bit of context as well in 2018 we
started on Google cloud with what I call
the cloud foundations so building what
the technical Landing Zone with the
different kind of governance in place
next we move to gke and utilize that to
great effect we go into githubs and we
can start with anthos
and 2020 that's where we achieve managed
services provider status so that we can
give that kind of a extra service to our
customers
and next we build things like
accelerators in a different waveform
workloads
now
so in back in 2018 to bring you back a
couple of years ago like four years back
there was a few different requirements
with the look at our Landing zone right
first we had to work on this different
different customers proof of Concepts so
you're building different pocs they're
using different kind of customer
environments so you have to build a
multi-tandent strategy
secondly we want to test out new
features on Google Cloud to be ahead of
the curve to understand what is going to
be the next Trend in the market and what
should we get ahead of to learn
and next we want to do it as automated
as possible because if you want to know
there's a big lack of talent in the
Google Cloud Market we need much more
developers much more Cloud attacks in
the market to get Google Cloud really
running as cool as possible so as a
byproduct automation is key
next we're going to make it intuitive
and easy to navigate for example if you
want to onboard a new engineer they
should be able to look at the cloud
landscape and understand where to go how
to navigate and how to build things so
it should be as close to best practices
as possible so that we do not have to
reinvent The View
and next last thing finally is to be
secure because we cannot lose
information and data right
so with that we looked around the five
uh six main topics so with things like
governance networking logging monitoring
security building because for example
building actually is a key part of
security as well how to prevent BioShock
we have to make it multi-tenant with
different customers sitting in different
environments as well as our own sandbox
environments for our developers
as uh and so and also we run Internet
applications for customers as well so
you can imagine it's a very large
multi-tenant environment with different
regulations different kind of rules for
different countries so it's a quite a
sprawling landscape so we sit almost
across three organizations if you if you
know the organizational node in Google
Cloud
thousands of projects hundreds of
folders
so in 2020 we we took a step back
because there was where really the cloud
really boomed and we said that okay we
need to identify which Technologies were
really key to get on board so that we
can leverage and accelerate
so first of all we say that okay we're
going to go with terraform right we're
not going to go with Cloud deployment
manager so to kind of adopt an open open
way of working I see some last in the
audience we looked at things like Cloud
build Argo CD which we found that really
fitted the way we work uh the decorative
way of working
and we came across also this idea of the
Google Cloud foundations
right and what is Google Cloud
foundations
this is where we realized that we had to
use this great tool that was produced as
open source it's called the cloud
Foundation toolkit scorecard so remember
the the scenario we came from we had a
large sprawling Cloud landscape with
multiple projects that fit with multiple
use cases pocs sandboxes production
environment staging environments that
you have teams in different countries
building all the time and delivering all
the time for over 2000 customers
how do we score ourselves on security so
this is where this came in uh I
recommend you can do that so what you do
is that you can write what I call
policies so this is a very typical
policy they can download from the from
the source reports so it's a very simple
one it's just basically anybody that's
not wg.com should never be older in the
in your project very simple very simple
rule right
so with discount policies I would want
to do a walk through so the first step
there's three easy way steps to do this
to check your Cloud security posture
today so three easy steps to get get
rated number one export your asset
inventory so understanding what sits in
your Cloud right just simply run this
g-hat commands is easy PV
and you get a list of all your service
accounts firewall rules applications
everything comes out in a huge Json file
it covers things like IM rules as well
as resources
next you get your policy library from
for safety security I'm not sure if
anyone has implemented for seti before
you can raise your hand
yeah for exactly great awesome yeah it's
I really recommend it as well it's a
continuously check checking your
security posture
so there's a great base policy Library
here so it gives you like the basic
defaults things like that um on the
owner rules right
clone it and then just run this command
CFT scorecard and you point to a policy
path and you and you point to where your
bucket sits where you have your asset
inventory
with that you get a list of violations
and the violations as well will link to
the different kind of rules that uh that
you have implemented in your policy
Library
so how do we tackle all these different
rules as well like what do we start with
first
so first we tackle the IM violations
because first we want to make sure that
no one's accessing the system that
shouldn't be accessing the system right
so
throughout the experience with customers
and with other people as well like a
simple thing like
restricting the age of how long your
service account key can live for
so for example how many of you have
service count keys that have been
floating around for example if you have
a new Joiner there or a person that left
the company and they bring along the
service account key with them
so actually if you don't have a rotation
policy today this thing will pop up as a
violation so you have a service account
keys that has lived for longer than for
some hundred days
this also then gives you an insight
about what you have to fix and what
policy you have to you have to implement
so this could be maybe a missing process
in your company onboarding and
onboarding phase so maybe developers
should download a new key every two days
for example from a bucket so make sure
that those keys will never be misused
just let it die and so this was a
typical constraint that we found out
okay we have some service count keys
that have been living for too long we
have deprecated them and really and
rotate them
and also fix our processes right
next we have to rethink the project
creation process so a lot of the kind of
flaws there are issues that we found in
violations was actually due to this how
you create a project right that's
actually a very simple thing to do you
go to Cloud console you click create
project and you're done right
like for example do you know that in we
create a new project in the quotas page
bigquery analysis is unlimited for
example so any developer can create a
project and can consume
20 000 rows of of bigquery that's cost
within one day if they're not careful
so how do you do that in a way that you
can actually uh be make sure that you
are as secure as possible
so we had to fix issues and the road so
we started writing additional
constraints so one of them for example
is identifying course cost owners and
countries of where they sit so making
sure that each project has its owner and
and also have a have a PR request rule
so that when you try to create projects
it must be validated by the CTO of the
country
so when we scan when I scan our hot
landscape as well we found that there
are many ways of labeling there was not
uh it's always hard to follow rules with
on Confluence for example when you
create a you create a documentation you
say that I want you to do this same way
most of the time it gets out of skew so
you need to still monitor it and see
which of this things that you have
documented down whether the processes
are followed so trust but always verify
so this is a way of verifying it
next we also have to think about
revoking our modules so remember we
chose terraform right and we started to
build with terraform and we start to use
our modules and we use a lot of Open
Source terraform modules so we just grab
Gary off from get GitHub
uh from uh Cloud Foundation
and we start to use them we want to go
fast right that's how you really
leverage open source
but we realized that you cannot assume
that open source actually automatically
meets all your needs of each customer
and this is the reason why we have to
create our own telephone modules they
were specific to gke pops up ASM for
example enter service mesh and I'll give
you a bit of argue example why
so if you go to the next slide like for
example in this this is a copy paste
from uh uh public GitHub repo for ASM so
in here when you create an enter service
mesh
on a GK cluster you enable the GK Hub
feature in the same code in the same
module right which means if you create
five and top service measures across
five clusters and if you destroy one of
them it will disable the feature for the
entire project
so this is kind of things that you have
to actually investigate when you look at
open source as well to see that even
though it is uh is something published
open source is public is well tested you
have to see does it fit your need and
can you understand what goes on
underneath as well
and this is what I realized doing doing
our security posture check
so that's what I found out so you only
will discover this when you try to
destroy the ASM you realize that oh tell
you the features disabled
and lastly we start to think about even
extend it further and do definition of
additional rules
so for example we have many customers
within FSI Healthcare Manufacturing
and all of them have different kind of
data locality requirements for example
so creating uh uh location violations so
understanding that some of the data sets
can only sit in certain location gives
you a way to verify their data should
only be in a different area if you do
the same thing for your GK clusters for
your your cloud storage buckets and so
and so forth so you can basically the
developer does something wrong they can
they'll be notified when you do a big
scan right
and this really make it very easy to to
adopt a pulse yes code approach uh we
should find works better
than merely maintaining a bunch of rules
as documentation
so some of the learnings that we had
uh so there's a Code binary page always
work hard on something uncomfortably
exciting
so why do I quite uncomfort
uncomfortably affecting with security
because
honestly who wants to look at your own
security rules at times because you're
worried okay I made something wrong I
did something wrong I might be the
reason for this uh security breach
so it's very important to open up those
those problems at surface up to yourself
rather than letting some attacker or
some some outside adversary discovery on
your own so it's uncomfortable but do it
do check your security posture
so and also with open source systems so
we will look at our security posture as
well we found out that um you know a lot
of cves are trying being updated on time
how to deploy it and as well as when we
recommend an open source system to work
on we also we have to understand can we
support this open source system
ourselves in the event that somebody
stops supporting it starts doing PR's
suspects stuff picking fixing bugs can
we go ahead and fix those bugs ourselves
and this is a great thing we love open
source and we love to we love to use it
but the thing is that if it goes away
from this open source system we'll be
stuck on it and you'll take a few months
to migrate from it so anything we pick
and choose we must go through a
checklist and we see are we able to
understand how can we support it
can we explain how it works so
understanding and explaining how it
works is very important as well
and can we extend it so that can we add
on to it is it something that's
protected and you can rebuild it
so next uh what's next in our list of
activities so in 20283 we're going to
start looking at things like kubernetes
config connector and opa open policy
agent
so like you see the constraints is just
defined on the screen so Google has come
up with a new way of working instead of
using terraform you create Google Cloud
infrastructure as yaml files right and
you deploy into KCC which is then
instantiate those resources on your
Cloud landscape and then you use things
like open policy agent to block any
misconfigured uh infrastructure
and that could be a possibility so it's
always important to update on the new on
the latest tech and see that it fit for
us
but we cannot only protect from uh from
attack at the source we also have to do
audits which is why something like the
the cloud Foundation toolkit is always
good to have because you can audit at
the end of the year to make sure that
you are in compliance
and also things like the security
Command Center so there's another
another new feature that Google came up
with I think last year
that has a lot of these constraints they
have defined for you with machine
learning and also with the different
benchmarks that you can easily purchase
and deploy
but right now we have our own policy
library that we maintain and that we use
to regulate our our infrastructure but
it could be a good idea to go to those
two in that
so yeah so it looks very similar you're
creating uh yaml files for like for
example constraint templates for Pub sub
so and ensuring that you have the labels
yes always labeled
and it's uh basically a gatekeeper so
ensuring that nothing gets gets sent in
that's wrong
and we'll secure a command center uh you
take things the next step so always
doing a asset infantry export so the
whole Square posture is always around
your assets taking the export trying to
figure out is there has it been any
misconfigurations and also do track
detection so that's something that's
also extra
that we're looking at
and also what's nice is that it has the
best practices there as well like CIS
NRC which we have built in our policy
libraries but it's nice to have somebody
updating it for us like moving to a
managed service always something that we
choose to do
also with that I end my session my email
is actually hidden by the round thing
but if you want to drop me a meal to ask
talk about security or ask about our
policy Library you know well who's happy
to share so it's json.quack
devilteam.com so feel free to drop me a
message anytime yeah I'd love to connect
on LinkedIn as well thanks
foreign
[Music]